- [Voiceover] We are told the square below
represents one whole.
So this big square here
represents a whole.
Express the shaded area as
both a fraction and a decimal.
So let's see, we've taken the whole
and we've divided it into
one, two, three, four,
five, six, seven, eight,
nine, ten, equal sections.
Each of these columns or
each of these tall rectangles
represent one tenth of the whole because
they are ten equal sections
that it has been split into.
So each of these is a tenth and let's see
we have filled in one,
two, three, four, five,
six, of those tenths.
So if I wanted to
represent it as a fraction
I would say this is 6/10 and
if I were to represent it
as a decimal I would say, okay, well,
I have zero ones and I have six tenths,
so as a decimal it is 0.6.
Let's do a couple more of these examples.
So let's say, so okay, look at that.
Now I have, let's see, the big
square represents one whole.
Express the shaded area as both a fraction
and a decimal.
So what's going on over here?
So I have ten rows and in
each row I have ten squares.
So ten times ten.
This has a hundred squares in it.
So I've divided my whole into
a hundred equal sections.
So each of these little
squares is one hundredth.
So here I have shaded in one, two,
three, four, five out of
the hundred hundredths,
or I could say I have five
hundredths right over here.
So as a fraction, I
could write this as 5/100
and as a decimal I could
say, oh, I have no ones.
I have no tenths and I
have five hundredths.
Let's do a couple more examples of this.
So let's say that I wanted to...
Let's see, it says, express
the location of the point
on the number line as both
a fraction and a decimal.
All right. So let's think about it.
So this is 2/10, this is 3/10.
And you see it is 0/10, 1/10,
or this is 0, 1/10, 2/10, 3/10,
and before each, or between each tenth
they've split it into ten equal sections.
One, two, three, four, five,
six, seven, eight, nine, ten.
So each of these, each
of these little hashmarks
represent one hundredth.
So one way you could view this is
we're at two tenths,
so we have two tenths,
and then we're going to
have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven hundredths.
So we could view this point as two tenths
and seven hundredths.
So actually let me write
it as a decimal first.
So we have two tenths and
we have seven hundredths.
Now another way to think about this
is we have 27 hundredth.
You can count them.
Remember each of these is one hundredth.
So zero, one, two, three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine, ten,
11, 12, 13, 14, 15, 16,
17, 18, 19, 20, 21, 22, 23,
24, 25, 26, 27, 27 hundredths.
And most people when they see this number
they won't say two tenths
and seven hundredths.
They'll just say 27 hundredths.
Well how do you write 27
hundredths as a fraction?
Well, it's 27/100.
27 over, over 100.
Let's do, I don't know,
I'm kind of in the mood.
Let's do one more of these.
The big square represents one whole.
Express the shaded area as both a fraction
and a decimal.
So we've already seen,
there's a hundred of these.
The whole is split into a
hundred equal, smaller sections.
So each of these small
squares is a hundredth
and so how many hundredths
do we have shaded in?
So this is going to be ten
hundredths, 20 hundredths,
21 hundredths.
So as a fraction I'd write that as 21/100.
Now, you could, there's a couple
of ways to think about it.
If we're familiar with it
already we would say okay,
look, two tenths is the
same thing as 20 hundredths,
so it's going to be two
tenths and one hundredth,
or 21 hundredth.
Another way to think about it is
this first row right over
here, that's a tenth,
then this next one is a
tenth, so you have two tenths,
and then you have a hundredth over here.
So any way you want to think about it.
This is 21 hundredths or two
tenths and one hundredth.